it's a really exciting day four new
elements have been named on the same day
I think the first time in the history of
the periodic table it's happened one of
the elements was created in Japan and
has a Japanese name so it's a great
excuse to wear my periodic table happy
this is made by one of our fans in Japan
and if you look it has the space to put
the names the new symbols of the four
elements and as well today happens to be
the eighth birthday of periodic videos
eight years since we shot the first
video welcome to our periodic table
videos this is an experiment for me just
as much as it will be for you when
you're watching and I just wanted to
begin by showing you bit my office and
explaining what the periodic table means
to chemists like me so now for the names
the first element number 113 over here
was discovered for all first synthesized
in Japan he's been called Nihon iam with
the symbol NH in honor of Japan
the second element number 115 is Muscovy
'm named after moscow capital of russia
which is not far from Dubois where the
element was synthesized 115 and the
symbol is MC which might actually appeal
to our viewers in scotland because as
you know many surnames in Scotland begin
MC so it's a sort of Russian Scottish
element the third element number 117 is
one of the halogens now you know the
halogens fluorine chlorine bromine
astatine all ending in irony so element
117 has been named Tennyson after the
American state Tennessee where many of
the elements were discovered
at Oakridge the National Laboratory I'm
not sure whether it's intended to be
pronounced Tennyson or Tennyson I prefer
Tennyson the last element 118 is one of
the noble gases
now all the noble gases apart from
helium end in O n neon argon Krypton
xenon radon and this one is been called
Logan s on now that's quite a strange
name and you might be a bit surprised
let me tell you the symbol is o G is
named after academician URI agony sein
who is an Armenian working in Russia and
is director of the Institute where many
of these elements were discovered see
alive he's alive
which makes him only the second person
in the history of the periodic table to
have an element named after them while
they're still alive
the other one was named after Seaborg
seaborgium though there is a rumor that
in Steiner about einsteinium before the
name was made public but he was dead
when it went public these names are
provisional as are the symbols and there
are six months for people to comment or
object and in some cases like the
element companies iam the symbol was
changed from CP to C n so it's possible
that some of these may change
I suspect that nobody is going to object
to them but we'll have to see what do
you think of the four names I think
they're all great I think the ogre
Nessun is perhaps slightly hard for some
people to pronounce but it's quite fun
now of course some people think the
periodic table is complete but if you
look at the sleeve of my Japanese happy
you can see
that their space is relevant 100 1920
keep watching periodic videos and I hope
quite soon there might be some other new
elements so we can continue completing
my sleeve professor does that mean if we
react Moscow avian with oxygen we'll
have much oxygen